*sweet music*
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the eggnog ice bath challenge
As you can see we have eggnog,
Twenty gallons of it.
And we have an ice bath.
And so were going to combine these two elements,
there's gonna be an incredible, chemical reaction out of it,
and then we are going to submerge ourselves in this
and discover the fountain of youth.
And in doing this we, are going to answer your twitter questions
about Christmas, our Christmas, your Christmas any Christmas in general.
We're going to get to the bottom of the answers here.
You have something to say Tyler?
*Tyler off screen* You said 'we'. Isn't it just you on this one?
Yeah Probably... Maybe
and I'm sorry if my voice is a bit gravely
I'm still sick, I-I thought I was getting better yesterday
and then I screamed for 5 hours straight
and suddenly my voice is a little bit deeper than it usually is.
But maybe that will be good this time.
So we are gonna get started
and we are gonna get a lot of footage
of us, dumping this egg nog in the ice bath.
*dope ass/electronic music plays*
We're wasteful!
Cue the sexy music
*Cricket Noises*
That was not sexy at all
That was the least sexy thing I've ever done in my life
Ok, here we go
Everybody ready?
Aghhhhhhhhhhhaahhhaa
mmm-awww
Its so slippery
agghh
Its-awwwwgh
AHHHHH
MMMM
**continued grunting in pain**
UnGGHHHH
Oh Shit
Hoo hoof hoof
MMMMMMMM
UNGHHHHHHHHHH
Hungh
Achkhk
**Wheezing**
UNGHHHHHHH
Hugghh
*Slams fist on bathtub*
Mghhhhhhuu
*Very loud breathing*
Ahhahh
Mmmmmmm
Ok, all right ok
mmmm Ok
Do not pour that on me.
It is colder than water
I will tell you that
It is like a-
It was like- its like an ice
Its like an ice
water
salt mixture
Cause there are so many
solllvents
I can't stay in here looooong
Ok, so
What did you ask Santa for this year?
Thankfully I'm lucky enough that I don't really ask for much these days.
One of things i wanted most is to be able to spend Christmas with my friends and family.
So I'm very happy to be able to do that.
Ohhhhh-Ohhhhhhh
festivleypewds asks "Will we ever get that christmas album?"
And I would really like to be able to get that Christmas album.
But to be honest, getting sick got in the way.
My voice isn't where it was.
And we were planning to do a full cover of a few Christmas songs.
BUUUUUUUUUUUTT
*struggling* Things got in the way.
But expect some cover songs of things very soon.
jackie/xmas said "Do you still believe in Santa Claus?"
I don't because that's not physically possible?
But I like the idea of Santa:
A big jolly old fellow that just yells at all his bastard kiddies.
theCatCadaver asks "What's your favorite Christmas movie?"
It's Jim Carrey's
*straining* How the Grinch Stole Christmas.
I watch it EVERY single YEAR.
This is uncomfortably close Tyler.
Just get a god damned shot from over there and
stop moving around like a goof!
Sugar plum Shaely asks "When/how did you find out that santa wasn't real?"
UHM WHEN I COULD FIRST THINK
Anybody that believes in Santa is just a BIG BABY
Actually I'm pretty sure my Dad never told us that Santa was actually real
P-p-pretty much I just think he wanted all the credit for all the presents anyway
HUUUUUUUUUUU
BOY
*Fast breathing*
**grunting**
Gabrielmemes asks "What are some family traditions your family usually does?"
We had this game called "hide the pickle"
And that may sound sexual but its not
We would hide a small pickle in the christmas tree
and if you found before anybody else you would get
BOOONUS PRESENTS
And
Eventually I stopped doing it after I had like NINE nieces and nephews THAT NEEDED TO WIN IT
*Random Gibberish*
IIIII DID.
*Growls*
at softyplier asks
OH NO that's ask softyler asks
"what made you think this was a good idea?"
Absolutely nothing
I knew this was gonna be a bad idea
Because
This is FARRRR colder than any normal ice bath
I CAN'T FEEL MY TOES OR BALLS!
AHHHH
Ethan(off-screen): Mark you look really thirsty
Do not
Ethan: I think you need a sip >:)
Do not, I'm serious.
I think you need a sip (x2)
Do not, I'm serious!
Do not
You need a sip.
You need a sip! (x2)
DONOT
TAKE A SIP MARK!
DO NOT!
YOU NEED A SIP!
DONOT!
You look really thirsty, take a sip!
FFFUCK YOU
It's really good
*heavy breathing/grunting*
**wheezing**
REPTARS GETTING NOGGY!
*gritting teeth/growling*
FUUUUCKK YOUUU
at markibach asks "How deep are you on the naughty list?"
Well as you can see, I'm about as deep as you can go.
Pretty much balls deep if you know what I mean
at Fallenfools asks "Why would you even
bathe in eggnog? Mark, why?"
I DON'T KNOW
I DIDN'T PREPARE FOR THIS
I'M A FUCKING IDIOT OKAY?
I JUST DO FOR VIEWS
THAT'S  IT!!!!
Oh my god so cold
Why didn't I fucking get questions before I got in the bath?
MMMMMM
"If you were a rapper, what would your stage name be & why?"
This is not a Christmas related question!
And awful-obviously it would be Markapimpdaddy29
FUCK
"Will yoyou give me the ziggity zucc?"
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUCK THAT MEANS
*Bang* (x2)
CHRISTMAS
"What's the worst gift you gave somebody?"
I don't actually give bad gifts
I think very carefully about
THAT'S A FUCKING LIE
I get everything last minute
Then usually I just do something technology related
and hope they don't mind.
I'm so bad,
that I just buy things from amazon,
and pay THEM to gift-wrap it
That's how bad at buying gifts I am
OHHHH MY TOES
ARE HURTIN'
*sniff*
MMMMM
*grunt*
at markfishbowl asks
"Does Chica have a Christmas sweater?"
Yeah she's got a lot of Christmas
outfits. We put her in angel wings and we wanted to put her in a halo
but she didnt actually take to the halo. She didn't like that. OOOOOH
Starting to get really cold
Oh my god x3
Aww my god
Ok
at what the hell is a name (wthisaname) said "travelling anywhere during the holidays gonna visit your family?"
Yes
We're gonna be DOOOING a a a
VACATION
Back in Cincinnati
I'm a be able to spend about 2 weeks with friends and family
Over the holidays
and that we're try to prepare for, that's why we're doing thiiiiiisss
URRRRRR
One more question!
WOOOOOO
at Knishmasfred asks "if you could choose, what would be your perfect christmas day?"
The perfect christmas day would be
one
where I could actually sleep in,
because I almost always get up at 8 A.M.,
go downstairs,
spend time with my
friends and family,
spend all day cooking,
enjoy opening presents
and seeing everybody else get their presents,
and just relax
for one day
and that's what I'm looking for.
So thank you for the question,
I'm gonna get the
fuck
out of this goddamn bath
Hooooo
Hooo
*breathing*
**painful whimper**
My Toes
My Toes x2
My Toes x3
Oh please put the the put th-the-the
Thethethethetehteehethe
*whining*
Uh
URRRAHHH
**jagged breathing**
Hoooooo
Hooo
Ho x3
Ho x4
Ho x5
Ho x6
Ho x7
Ho x8
it's
fucking
cold
now
I'm gonna go in the shower
oh shit
oh shit x2
OW
OH!
OH x2
HE HAH HO HAH
OW
HO HE HAH
HE HA
This water is warm and if it was in the ice bath then it's pure cold
*Tyler chuckling*
OH
MY
GOD
My toes hurt so baaaaaadly
So uh, I'm gonna be here for a while.
Hope you guys enjoyed the video
Thank you so much for watching
and thank you for all your questions
This was very stupid.
I don't know why we did it.
Ethan, why did we do this?
Ethan(off screen): Uh because it was my idea
Yeah that was your idea GET IN THE FUCKING BATH
nononoononno
no
no x2
No x3
TYLER
Please
Please x2
Okay so we're all done here thank you everybody so much for watching
and if your asking yourself,
Yes! it was horrible
Right Ethan?
Ethan(off screen): Yes it was the worst thing
Yeah
It was pretty bad.
because the eggnog has different things besides water in it such as salt and sugar and fats
which if you know
When you put salt in ice, it makes it actually colder
than freezing temperature water
so that was extremely cold
But! we got to answer some of you guys' christmas related questions
so thank you everybody so much for watching
and now I'm gonna drain this
demon bath
but I have to stick my Ahhhhhh
OH
That's good.
But either way
Thank you Tyler, Thank you Ethan and thank you guys so much for joining us.
and as always, we will see you in the next video,
BU BYE!